هذه المره من القدس تنضم الينا مساحه
الاقصى المراسله لنا كلاسي اهلا بك يا
لانا نبدا باجواء رمضان في ساحه الاقصى
اهلا بك رمضان كريم
اهلا بك رمضان كريم يعني نحن هون هنا
نتواجد في ساحه المسجد الاقصى المبارك حيث
توافد عشرات بالمئات من الفلسطينيين
للصلاه في المسجد ايضا كان هناك اعداد من
الفلسطينيين قد قدموا مع الافطار زينه انا
ورامي زوجي رامي هو اليوم
طبق على فكره
تحياتنا لالكم من استوديو مساء العربيه من
دبي الى القدس سلمولي على القدس واهلها
اكيد نادين انت ممكن جربتي هاي التجربه
احنا حاليا
وسموها بالمقلوب الفلسطينيه لانها تقلب
وهاي
يعني هاي التجربه الاولى لرامي
تفضل اولا اول مره كمان رامي بيجرب هاي
التجربه وبيعمل مقلوبه مش بس احنا يعني
هون كل الاشخاص حوالينا بس انتم شويه
تاخرتوا علينا الاذان كان له ثلث ساعه اذن
كمان جابوا اغراضهم جدا جميله رمضانيه
اطفال كبار بالسن كله عائلات هنا تتواجد
واجواء رمضانيه جدا
طيب احنا لنا يبدو انه في مشكله في
الارسال
التجربه الاولى
بنشكر كلانا وطبعا منشير انه هذه اجواء
وطقوس متوارثه من ساحه